all right i think we can start and thank
you so much for joining this session
today i'm very sorry i cannot join you
guys i wasn't sure that i will have
a success getting to oslo but yeah
welcome to the conference i hope your
day was great and today uh right now i
would like to talk about desktop
development in dot net 6.
first very quickly about me i'm a senior
program manager at microsoft working on
dotnet team and my primary focus is
dotnet desktop so i am pm of winforms
wpf i also work on dotnet maui together
with my co-workers and i'm um i'm
spending a lot of time on importing
story from older.net platforms to dotnet
six or the latest.net so if you have any
questions feel free to ping me on
twitter anytime and i'll find the answer
or i'll connect you to people who can
talk to you about your
issues and first very briefly i wanted
to talk about dot net in general what is
that and that's our latest platform so
you probably all know that net framework
and then we had dotnet core we also had
dotnet standard as another option to
target and uh xamarin was available in
maui so in dot net six we connected
everything in one cross platform open
source uh solution and that is a unified
development platform for building
anything you can use the same tools
libraries language and runtime to build
any application across web mobile
desktop
ai data gaming and iot workloads and net
in general purpose programming platform
enables all kind of applications and
scenarios once you learn one you can
easily pick another to enable specific
apps scenario app model or an app
framework uh you're building on top of
the base libraries and runtime
to expand what dot net can do so it's
one common base libraries it's same apis
all over the place same language you
don't need to learn different
technologies you can stay in the same
ecosystem
and dotnet has a vast ecosystem of
thousands of libraries
library packages
via nougat and open source projects in
development on github there are also
hundreds of vendors providing adding
component agent components tools
libraries and services and you can use
broad set of ideas there is visual
studio visual studio for mac visual
studio code and even cli if you prefer
that so dotnet 6
has a huge uh involvement of open source
community
that net ecosystem has been
has got significant momentum in the last
few years there are now 5.4 million
monthly active developers in visual
studio family of tools and netcore and
dotnet5 has ranked number one three
years in a row as the most loved
framework on stack overflow developer
survey cloud native computer foundation
tracks the highest velocity projects on
all of github they measure this by the
rate of pull requests
and issues that come in and how many are
exp accepted
the dot net repo have been consistently
in the top 30
since 2017
and there are almost 7 000
people outside microsoft that made over
21 000 contributions there filed issues
or submitted pull requests suggested
features
to the dot net related repositories for
net six release and if you're one of
them i want to thank you thank you very
much for helping us building those
platforms together
and
i wanted also to talk very quickly about
dot net six performance we're always
focused on having the best performance
here you can see the tech empower
performance comparison with java and
node.js and better performance leads to
lower computer cost and the net gets
better every release many of these
improvements were made by the community
by the way so dotnet six web framework
asp.net core is still over 10 times
faster
than node.js and we've also worked
really hard on entity framework core
performance if core performance on
dotnet 6 has improved 92 percent over
dot net 5. and that gain you just
getting from simply moving from.net 5 to
newton 6. also query performance is 36
percent better than document 5.
so dotnet 6 is released we just released
this this november and it has unified
common based libraries and sdks uh great
performance simplified development
easier to get started
you probably
heard or will hear about c-sharp 10
improvements we also have f-sharp six
released uh we have support for apple
silicon arm64 and dotnet six is a long
term version what that means that we're
gonna support it for three years and
recently wiz.net we switched to a new
schedule now we're releasing a new
version every year we received the
feedback that before the way we were
doing it before when we were releasing
it whenever we had something to release
was not optimal for you guys because you
wanted more like predictable schedule
and now we promise to release a new
version every year and every second year
that will be a long term version so one
year we're innovating we're introducing
new apis and second year we are
stabilizing everything and we're
supporting every second version for
longer time so for those who prefer to
switch only
once in a while you can stay on longer
version you have about three years
before you migrate
and
also we released visual studio 2022 that
has absolutely great tooling and many
improvements and these are features
specifically for
dotted desktop
so we have hot reload we have xaml live
preview i will show both further in the
talk we have intellicode improvements
such as whole line completion
suggestions for common code refactoring
on the fly
we have built-in git and github
integration to clone repo manage work
items and pull requests and
automatically set up ci cd workflows to
github actions and azure and visual
studio 2022 is the first 64-bit version
of visual studio so it can take
advantage of the full power of your dev
box to work on projects of any size and
scale
to get it go to visualstudio.com and
download it today and of course there is
a ga version there is also preview
version that has the latest features
so
one special thing that i wanted to
spend time to talk separately is hot
reload
in this visual studio we got hot reload
everywhere that's one of my favorite
feature and we've enabled it for all
platform it's winforms wpf maui
everywhere
hut reload is not just for dotnet 6
developers it works on multiple project
types and all that net version starting
from 4.6 and higher than framework 4.6
that support edit and continue and
dotnet 6 is the most optimized for the
best hot reload experience it has
ability to use hot reload when starting
the app without a debugger and other
latest improvements and features so
still best hat reload we got in dotnet
six
and uh let's talk about actually let's
talk about what is new in wpf
specifically
with dot net six
so
wpr we have xaml live preview and i'll
show that you in a minute what is that
but we received requests to
um
now our users complain that when they're
building applications on one monitor
it's not always convenient to switch
between running code and
visual studio because with hot reload
now you can edit your code and you see
changes in the running application but
when you edit the code you need to see
your application and we brought
application inside visual studio in one
of the visual studio windows and we also
added some tooling on top of it for
enabling pixel perfect ui
we have a quick action feature
that is a light bulb that appears next
to your control in the designer and
allows you to get access to
most uh commonly used properties inside
the designer so you can change basic
properties with one click
we have design time data and sample data
i'll show you that in a second as well
uh we have xaml binding improvements
so you can see here in the
on the picture we modified the dialogue
we added
ability to
get a quick access to uh commonly used
scenarios we have intellisense
improvements for mvvm scenarios xaml hot
reload uh
we updated a xaml designer for dotnet
framework projects meaning that okay we
had our older designer or dotnet
framework then we
built a new out of process designer for
net core projects and now we finally
moved to
one designer that is a new out of
process designer that now supports
dotnet framework dotnet core so
what that means you get better
performance you get more reliable
designer a more convenient designer for
you to use you probably won't notice
anything but behind the scenes that's
what's happening now we're back to one
code
for the designer for both dotnet core
family and dotnet framework
and
let's go to visual studio and see all
those new features that i just talked
in action
so
here i have air quality application that
shows
quality of air in different cities
recently we had some troubles in us with
fires and very bad
quality of the air where we needed to
stay home we needed to make sure like
the quality is okay for opening windows
and so on so that inspired me to build
this very simple demo app that will show
air quality for each city that i will
bring into my
form
and
i am getting air quality with this
following data template
right and the way i do it i have very
basic ui in place
i do it
i put in grid i'm putting this data
binding i pass to aka quality etc well
what i see in the designer i see nothing
because my
data comes from data binding and now you
have a feature that allows you to see
that inside your designer without
running your application this feature is
called design time data
and the way it works you can add any
property
with d column
and that will mock data in your design
time so it would not take effect on your
real application on your binary but if
you want to do some edits here and you
can also set certain text you can set
certain properties values anything you
want that will never affect your
production code and i just set some mock
data here test data i see it immediately
in my designer all right awesome i can
see how that looks if i'm happy with ui
and i'm mostly happy but i probably want
to make this pop out
this is our next feature is called
design quick actions quick actions is
the slide bulb that appears next to
control and when i expand it i get
access to the most commonly used
properties for this specific control we
got
stats and we try to put something that
you are using the most for this control
and okay let me try to make it oh it was
bold already let me try to make it
slightly bigger
right
yeah i think i am happy with how it
looks now and i'm ready to run my
application
okay
and
now i need to find this app or somewhere
on my other screen among
one million open windows here it is all
right the application runs but something
is wrong i'm expecting to see my ct is
here and it's
empty that means something is broken and
you know that's what usually happens
when i develop applications so i'm gonna
debug it but what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
debug it while it's running and i will
make my changes to the running
application
the way i'm gonna do it here i have only
one screen so i will use that xaml live
preview feature so let me
slide
i'm gonna type zamo live preview here it
is
open and this window shows my real
running application exactly the way it
looks i'll run it here to show you guys
and now okay perfect i can put it
somewhere it can be underneath my visual
studio i see it right here it's a
standard visual studio window so i can
talk it i can resize it and can make it
wherever i prefer
to have it
another great thing i can zoom in and
zoom out and it has some additional
tooling
so what i'm gonna do now i'm gonna fix
my app okay yeah i see here i forgot
item source
so i'm gonna add this
and
i will add
binding
path
and you know what would be nice if i
could get intellisense on this path
because i have my viewmodels
there's the visual studio should be able
to do that and now it can
if i go here and add
set design
the data
context that is another feature that we
have now
i'm getting intellisense perfect and now
i got my cts i got my cts and iranian
application amazing now i can really use
my uh
xaml live preview feature i can zoom in
see if everything is aligned there is
some rulers
that will show me the distance to the
top to the left all right great i can
even change the color for those rulers i
can make them if i add too many for my
designer purposes and then i want to
hide them and then bring them back i can
do that i can even get some information
on the controls i can see the borders i
can get the
size spawned foreground and so on so
that's something you also asked us
because you liked some features from
blend and you wanted to be able to have
the tooling for pixel perfect ui now you
have it in xaml live preview all right
i'm happy with everything
except one thing you know i noticed that
all my cities for some reason are los
angeles which doesn't seem right so
that seems that is issues in my data
provider and i'm gonna fix that okay
yeah i added some test code that
overrides every city to los angeles
so i'll fix this and did you notice now
i'm changing c sharp code before i was
changing xaml code so we got xaml hot
reload now i'm changing c sharp code
and
my changes once i saved it they are
already applied
the thing the the question that i'm
getting asked why application has not
updated well application hasn't updated
because i need to trigger that code pass
that triggers the change right and when
i'm getting my um
cities uh
that's when i'm clicking refresh button
so i'm gonna click refresh button now
let me bring my app so you can see that
what i'm doing i'm gonna click refresh
button
all right did i save that
one second with this open out panel
that's not true yeah so this is the hot
reload um
the hot reload menu and uh oh
there is a check
hot reload on file save so when once i
do that
now i don't need to hit hot reload
i can say just save features and
now you can see that all my cities are
actually
real cities instead of that los angeles
the reason why i needed to hit a refresh
button because i needed my
program to go through the code that
updates the ui one more time but the
changes were already there that change
in the data layer were immediately there
once we
hit save
all right
i'm happy with this app i'm gonna stop
it and go back to my deck for now
million different windows
okay now let's talk about winforms what
is new in winforms
well we got some new features and of
course we worked on the designer so we
got application white font default font
and that is a special story
once we um
updated to dotnet core we were able to
address the request that we heard from
you guys for many years the thing is
that long long time ago default font was
a microsoft sans serif then uh with time
it changed to sigou ui but in winforms
it still remained microsoft sensory for
many years because we couldn't change we
couldn't make some breaking changes in
dotnet framework
switching to.net core model we were able
to introduce changes without being
afraid to break older applications
because they can be on.net framework and
you are able to have different versions
on the same machine and choose for each
app which version you want to target so
we made the switch for the font and the
problem was that for some older apps was
very intense ui
and pixel perfect ui now with the
default font everything did not look as
good as before and you ask okay i want
to go back to the older font so now we
provided uh api and the way you can
change your default font once it's one
li one liner
for all your applications and everywhere
where you override the font when you
specify the different uh font it's gonna
be what you specified but the fonts that
are using default setting will be set to
whatever font you want it to be and i'll
show that in the demo soon
we also got accessibility improvements
and we got a new data binding we're
still working on that feature but we're
investigating the ways how
these days developers prefer to use data
binding in their modern applications and
of course we're working on high dpi
fixes for the designer we got a strip
control editing from the designer so
before that was enabled only from the
code now we added the way how you can
change it in the designer for menu strip
context menu strip status strip tool
strip and other strip controls
we got a lot of fixes for
to improve the reliability of the
designer and now is much better uh we
made improvements in multiple control
editing scenarios so now if you're
selecting 30 40 controls you can easily
move them around copy paste etc the
before in the
previous version of the designer we had
some issues so we fixed that
um we've got uh third-party controls in
sdk we're working with all
with third-party vendors
and making sure that their controls have
a clear pass in our latest versions of
bin forms and if you are a control
vendor it doesn't matter if you're a
large company or you're just one dev and
you have any
questions of how to
enable your controls please feel free to
reach out to me i'm happy to work with
you i'm happy to set up
meetings to give you documentation
guidance whatever you need for your
success
and what else oh yeah we made
improvements in the designer load so
previous version was loaded when the
first time you're opening the form it
took some time now it's much faster and
it's done async so you can start working
on other projects while your form is
loading it doesn't block you
okay another thing that i wanted to talk
in especially winforms area is the
performance bins so we
improved our code and we did some major
refactoring in vin forms we reduced the
amount of allocations per withdrawal and
here you can see that
these are oh not here but here
these are um
same applications one is running on.net
framework and exactly same is running
on.net six
and for example for data grid view it
takes
kilobyte
and 4.06
oh sorry coming back it's only 77 then
only 14.
only seven so
that all you get by simply switching
from dotnet framework to dotnet six this
is how much
faster and less memory you will get
just from changing the framework
underneath your application
just a reminder that is not new in dot
net six we got it earlier but we got a
new task dialog that's a new control and
we have not been adding much in winforms
before but now as we made it open source
we received lots and lots of
contributions from open source community
and this control was done by our open
source contributor constantine prizer so
he suggested the feature he created pull
request he was joining us on our api
review meetings and we worked together
and we added his control into dotnet 5
so that is a message box on steroids you
can now customize a message box to the
way you like it you can enable
everything there like footers headers
check boxes as you can see whatever many
pages it's amazing control and we are
very thankful to the contributor and to
many others who helped us develop
winforms
so if you are thank you very much if you
are thinking about it it's super easy
you can just go to vinforms repository
github pinforms and we have issues that
are marked up for grabs feel free to get
them work on them
maybe we'll work together and yeah
another new control also we edited in
dot net 5 that is a web view so if you
develop with winforms you're probably
familiar with web browser but that one
was using older
browser and webview 2 is the latest
control that is chromium based now you
can add
web content inside your desktop
application as you can see here i have a
winforms app
and i just inserted twitter there
so if you need some web capabilities
inside your desktop that's super easy to
do with webview 2 w2 is available for
wpf as well as winforms and it is
distributed as
microsoft.web.webview 2 nougat package
you simply add it to your application
and you have a full
designer support you see it in the
toolbox you drag and drop you work with
it like with a regular control
okay we made some
accessibility improvements so making
windows forms application more
accessible to more users is one of the
big goals for our team and in dot net 6
we improve the way how assistive
technologies such as narrator or test
test automation can interact with the
controls
in winforms we do it we are adding ui
providers to the controls and that way
narrator for example can interact with
those providers in dotnet six we added
ua providers for checkbook clicks
check checklist box i'm sorry
linked label panel scroll bar tab
control track bar
we also improved narrator announcement
in data grid view error provider and
list view
another thing that we did we added
keyboard tooltips for the tab controls
tab page and tree views tree node
and we
improved color contrast in the following
controls
that's checked list box data grid view
label property grid view tool strip
button etc so
as uh we are receiving many requests for
making applications accessible and we
also realize that's a big responsibility
to make sure that
all that you guys are building is
accessible and you don't need to spend
time on it we are trying to take care of
everything for you
another thing high dpi fixes yes that
was a big issue with winforms and we are
fixing it started from net core uh net
5.06
and in this release we made some
progress in supporting pair monitor v2
so
now we can create controls in the same
dpi awareness as the application and we
can correctly scale container controls
and mdi child windows in premonitor v2
mode in most scenarios of course there
are still few specific scenarios like
anchoring and some controls like months
calendar
where the experience remains subpar but
you can see improvements from big left
to right from dotnet 5 to 0.6 so we're
getting there
uh we also and that is the topic of the
whole net is simplification it's less
code on your screen you're trying to
hide everything that is not needed and
in dotnet 6 and c sharp 10
brought a lot of simplifications to the
way how we write code and of course we
supported all those changes in our
desktop platforms so in winforms um we
supported the
implicit usings and file scope
namespaces so the code looks less busy
and easier to read can see from left to
right i'll also show that briefly in the
demo
and uh last thing before i jump to demo
when you type dotnet new before you
would see all that
huge list
and we simplified that as well
now that's the only thing you see and
all other um
templates are also available but we've
heard that this huge list is very
confusing people are getting lost
especially those who are just getting
started programming now it's more clear
and we have winforms wpf console class
blazer server razer maui if you have it
installed on your machine
all right and let's jump into demo and
look at winforms
second let me
switch gears here
okay let me just make sure that i'm
using the right version
of my app because i have a few
and while if you have any questions
i'm happy to answer them
right
all right
let's bring this up here
and what i have here that's the same
air quality but i added
a winforms hat so that's our wpf
and i also added
see here
i added air quality dot wind forms so i
try to put similar ui there and um
yeah let's the first thing that we'll do
this is my um air quality winforms
actually let me open
project file yeah
and let me show you implicit usage so
that's the feature i was talking about
i can add implicit usings
yes there you go
and set it to true
and now
many unions are not required anymore so
let me
save that
such using as system or system windows
forms well you know what visual studio
should figure out that's a vinforms
application of course i need that
there's no need to put it in your file
there's no need to overwhelm you with
that so now i can remove those fusions
and tada
that's just that another simplification
that we have in dotnet 6 and pinforms
supports that as well
that's
you can just add semicolon after your
namespace and you can move everything
let's see
come on there is my shortcut
basically you can move everything one
layer up you don't need another curly
braces bracelets braces it will just
work all right
then next thing default font we have an
api for this and you can
do applications set default font
specify what you want which font you
want for that
or you can do even better way you can go
to your project file here oh that's my
form let's go back to project file and
you can specify this font
here
as a
default font i i'll get you the um the
signature later i don't want to spend
too much time on it and if you're
specified
in project file then it will be applied
to the designer and to the runtime so
what actually i'm gonna do let's do
uh i have a details form here so when i
click on the city
i can get some basic um information
about that city pollution and let's say
i want to switch this this is all
default font i want to switch that to
this
rows that should be very curly so we
should be able to immediately see the
difference let me run the app
and
oh there there it is i got this form
yep as you can see all my default fonts
now look
very different perfect
another thing that i wanted to show you
oh and by the way while i'm working did
you notice that i have a different color
for tops i have like
orange
purple
second let me exit this one
i have there's orange there's blue
that is a new feature that we have it's
super easy to enable it you can go to
tools options
tabs and windows and here choose
colorize document tabs i did it by
project you can also do it by file
extension so that's a delighter that
i really enjoy another
thing related to this delighters is
seaming we supported a lot of different
themes you can go to
tools theme get more themes and now i'll
bring
this window here here you can choose
between many many different
themes let's look at this one oh this
one doesn't have a
color but some of them are very colorful
interesting so to get it simply download
and it will appear in your visual studio
you can switch to any
coloring theme of your preference
all right the last thing i wanted to
show you because i also want to talk
about porting is a new way of data
binding and in winforms we enable a way
you can data bind to your um
application uh you can for example here
that is a label i can go to data binding
and actually i have data binding already
in place but on the text you can open
the menu and you can click add new
object data source there you will pick
your data source i already picked it and
the only thing i need to do
um
let me open my form
here
but you need to pass that
in your uh form
so i'm passing city air quality that's
the
data i wanted to show
and now once i run it instead of that
provider label i should have
information about my weather provider
all right let's see
where is my form
oh there it is
sorry i'm navigating between so many
windows one
under another and there it is
all right
also i have a very different scaling
factor i have a huge monitor underneath
48 inch with one dpi and scaling factor
and the presentation monitor so yeah
windows is doing pretty good for high
dpi in the conditions i put it under
so yeah here's the data binding that's a
new way you can data bind to your
model view model
all right let's go back
here
and
let's briefly very briefly talk about
new offerings in a desktop world we have
dotnet multi-platform api or for
short.net maui that's another way how
you can do desktop
in.net and that option is cross-platform
it's um
evolution of xamarin forms designed to
help you develop
deliver high performance cross-platform
native desktop and mobile apps all from
a single code base so you can write it
once and you can have it on your mobile
devices on your desktop we support
windows mac mac os ios and android on
windows we are using win ui underneath
we are using mac catalyst for mac os and
of course ios and android and dot net
maui abstracts all those frameworks into
a single framework built on.net six and
dotnet maui on windows supports win ui
as i said allowing these apps to use all
the newest native features on supported
versions of windows
and that means you can build all these
applications for any device from a
single code base and project system
instead of learning different stacks and
languages for each you can use one
language and one set of libraries and
one ui stack for all of them
it will be released
in spring 2022 but the preview version
is already available it's preview 10 it
has windows app sdk dependencies they're
fully included more controls including
collection view indication view etc it
has a performance improvements for
android startup layout improvements and
many bug fixes and the best visual
studio for maui is visual studio 17.1
preview one so not the ga but the
preview version because we added a lot
of stuff there since ga
and another desktop i wanted to talk
about is a hybrid apps with blazer and
dotnet maui so we first supported blazer
on server then in the browser with web
assembly and now we're extending it
again so you can write blazer hybrid
apps this means you can create hybrid
client apps which combine web and native
ui together in a single native client
application
it is primarily targeted at web
developers that want to provide rich
client and offline experience for their
users and blyzer hybrid apps is built on
top of dotnet maui so it's dotnet maui
and then webview 2 that we talked about
already and then we're hosting
blazer in that webview2 in.net maui and
it relies on ui stack for a native
application container and native
controls
should you want to use them blyzer
desktop app have full access to the
machine so you can do things like call
native apis access the file system write
multi-threaded applications always the
high performance and optimal memory
consumption you get with net and you can
do this with pure web technologies so if
you want the combination of web and
desktop that is a an option for you
these scenarios will also be supported
with the maui releases early next
year and
now i wanted to spend some time about uh
on token uh how you can upgrade to the
dot net six to the latest.net there are
two options if you're upgrading from.net
core it's super easy in visual studio
you simply open uh go to properties
target framework there is a combo box
you change it to
dotnet six and that is true
between.net4.net5.net
because that's one family of the
platform so you can switch back and
forth very easily another uh
thing is when you're trying to
all right
when you're trying to
work fro from.net framework 2.6 so
one thing i wanted to mention uh we have
a breaking changes uh documentation so
let me open this breaking changes to
show you very quickly how you can use
that
so 4.net 6 we have many
areas let's go let's find winforms for
example these are breaking changes from
dotnet 5 to.net 2.6 we have just a few
and you can see binary compatibility or
source compatibility
you can go to the change you can see
this was the old behavior
this is the new behavior we got some
simplifications
and change category why did we change it
and recommended actions but we tried to
make dot net six very compatible with
net five so all those changes there
probably won't affect you and you just
have a very easy transition from dotnet
5 to 0.6 if there is something then you
have a guidance what to change and it
should be very quick change
all right now how do you port from
from.net framework 2.06 well in this
case migration is much harder because
dotnet framework was built many years
ago and then we
re-architected.net platform without
network completely it's a completely
different uh gears are in the underneath
so we cannot just switch it in visual
studio like you do it between.net or
family of platforms but we have a tool
for you that can help you upgrade
and
move to dotnet six we released the
great assistance that helps you
modernize older.net framework code bases
it's command line it is a command line
tool that gives you step-by-step
instructions for upgrading to the latest
version of net
and we've had over 4
40 000 downloads now what let's just
jump into the demo and i'll show you how
it works
so for this one i have a simple demo
app it's a dotnet framework application
yes here it targets dotnet framework 4.7
and i'm gonna bring a grid assistant and
just run it so i have it already on my
machine but it's super easy to get it
it's a global tool as i mentioned you
just
upgrade assistant install and you get
that uh let's look in the help it has a
few options
so for comments you can analyze upgrade
or you can add your extensions if you
run analyze it will just analyze your
code but it will not
do any changes if you run upgrade let me
actually find
like i do
to run upgrade you simply specify the
pass to your solution or project and it
starts analyzing it for you so
thinking of a great assistant you can
really imagine an assistant that does
all the work and asks you only when the
decision making
is needed so here it asks do i want to
backup my project usually i would say
yes but to save some time here i will
say no
now we are going to convert project file
to sdk style so
sdk style
if i could double click on my project
here
nothing happens
to see my project file i need to unload
the project and then this is my old
style project file
i have a very simple app and yet it's
many pages of this uh xml code
with net core and later we switch to
new project file uh style it's sdk style
and that one is much easier to read much
nicer to work with
and um
there's my upgrade assistant i'll bring
it back
i'm gonna
upgrade to this sdk project style now so
another good thing about this upgrade
upgrading you can
do one step at a time you can go to
visual studio you can make sure
everything works everything is fine then
you can continue
alright i just converted project file
style to sdk this step is complete now
i'm gonna clean up nuget package
reference
i'm gonna proceed with that
then we will update tfm
updating tfm it's a target framework
moniker so now we're actually switching
from dotnet framework to dotnet six and
the tool detected that the best match
for us as for tfm is dotnet six dash
windows because we have a bin forms
application and that is the
tfm for that so i'm gonna
press continue
and we're gonna update nougat packages
now
so upgrade assistant works for many
types of applications it's winforms wpm
but also sp.net console etc
and uh okay now we inform specific stuff
so it detected that
uh there is a default font api that has
changed so it's going to update the
default font
okay
and
inform source update
as
anything finalizing
all right i think we're done we're
moving to the next project in my case i
had only one project so that is it
press enter to continue upgrade has
completed okay let's go back to visual
studio reload the project
and see how that works okay immediately
when i click on my project i can see a
new sdk style project file which is
great right it's much smaller and when i
click right click properties
now you will see it targets.net six
instead of dotnet framework so now it
runs on.net six
the upgrade wasn't too bad let me run
the app make sure it works exactly the
same way but now it's on the frameworks
on the dot net six so it has much better
performance it has all the benefits of
the net six
where is my application is
oh there it is i found it
yep it runs and here
this app runs on 600 also it runs on.net
6.
perfect
so with that we are at a time and just
very quickly here are not supported in
dot net six areas and
the uh recommendations so for asp.net
web forms we recommend blazer or razer
pages
for server side wcf
consider web api jrpc or core wcf and
for remote and consider stream json rpc
or grpc or web api and
right get started today get dotnet 6 get
new visual studio
use upgrade assistant definitely move
your applications if you have anything
on.net framework and feel free to ask me
any questions if you have thank you so
much for your time i i'm happy to take
any questions
if that is possible i'm not sure how
we'll do it in this setup but
if there is moderator you guys can help
me
otherwise
otherwise i guess you can just reach out
to me on twitter and ask your questions
i'm happy to talk to you
thank you so much